الطريقه التي تتم بها معامله الصحفيه
الجزيره الغير مقبوله ابدا هناك حديث عن
تعذيب وحبس انفراتي هذا غير مقبول ابدا
لكن السلطات المصريه
والقياده السياسيه يبدو انها تقبل وتقر
هذه المعامله
صحافه ليست جريمه الجريمه ان يوقف الصحافي
وان يعذب وان تنتهك انسانيته تلك هي
الجريمه الصحافه ليست جريمه ثلاث سنوات ان
تتوضع في اي شيء تحقق معه ثلاث سنوات يعني
هذه لو خليه ارهابيه ارتكبت من الجرائم
ارتكبت لا يمكن ان تبقيها ثلاث سنوات قيد
التحقيق يعني ماذا تحقق مع صحفي ثلاث
سنوات
[موسيقى]
شبكه الجزيره نحن نطالب باطلاق سراحه فورا
ومن دون قيد او شرط كما نطالب باطلاق سراح
الزميلين ايضا في الجزيره مباشر هشام عبد
العزيز المعتقل منذ ما يقرب اربع سنوات
دون تقديمه لاي محاكمه وايضا الزميل ربيع
الشيخ المعتقل منذ ما يقارب العام النصف
قربت شبكه الجزيره العالميه عن قلقها
الشديد على سلامه الزميل بهاء الدين
ابراهيم وزميليه هشام عبد العزيز وربيع
الشيخ المحتجزين كذلك دون محاكمه في
زنازين تفتقر لابسط شروط الصحه والنظافه
يبدو المساله تتعلق بقرار السياسي لمعاقبه
قناه الجزيره كمؤسسه وكان هؤلاء الصحفيون
هم ضحيه لهذه العمليه
متضامنه مع صحفيين الجزيره وربيع وهشام
واطالب بالافراج عنهم الصحافه ليست جميله
انه امر مشين تماما ان يتم
احتجاز وتوقيف وحبس صحفيين لاكثر من ثلاث
سنوات ومن دون ان تتم محاكمتهم ويجب ان
يكون هناك ضغط على اعلى المستويات لكي يتم
اطلاق سراح الزملاء اذا اعلم ان الكثير
منظمات حقوق الانسان في العالم وفي الشرق
الاوسط تطالب بعمل شيء وبمحاسبه مصر ومن
اجل اطلاق سراح زملائنا هؤلاء
[موسيقى]